широко ну ці астані думалося норманської
четвірки про пункти в кутку на
донбасі
а вибори світшот з артема депутат до
європарламенту чи дні машиною риба до
горам приїхала на донбас саржі та третій
мова на лінію фронту
у мене кожен від рук і страх коли я
перебуваю біля лінії фронту
віджимання може працювати з чесно і
передматчевої али за зростанням моєї дієти
рудим пунктуації у вогні побачиш
tashtego виеби авдіївка втомимося від і
женця місця пробував знову маже по
стін і обстрілів сотня параанальних
то троє за гоблак сучасних мішкан сил
зла mkiv снаряді забрати з роком ходж
утиліти пам'ятник жертвам ти їй провини
закиньте а сич нього разом буллу
вибухового праворуч знак 300
різьблених об'єктив і ціль будинок один з
їх шляху квартирі перебував двоє перед
kill наше щастя геть та не заглянув та
між consert чотирьох квартир у ритуалі
1000 їх нілів будинку мартена квартира ви
сайт нову точку змінити стіни буду
може з поділася вона краще помірно
вірити вже в якій оголошено перемир'я
вуста не в суспільстві місця тут не вул.
останків
гулу зруйную ми висимо квартир ви люди
ну було пурана не ребека norms і twitter
також вас по середню лінію фронту на
броньованому автомобілі без преси
надходив ваккун вони мінських
домовленостей євро депутат до там не
побачила
а дошки сайт ти одна сторона так званих
сепаратистів так тосы вояки Петро їм піти
руси і допомагаю тобі дали більше за хобот
і території як контролю я україна лише
контур б'є з кабінету
лінії розмежування про і куди вмивалася
чим мінському, що впав
сьогодні знаходиться на два кілометри дали
адже і їй лінії
ден мінівер бувають шпалери вигляді знов та ми
виразом і видом вежі ребекка хармс
power таїті у брюссель свої виставкою
диво вважаєте на сході українців чернець
краще уявіть коліно у
європарламенті
смоленськ ситхах у нас мінську до
молодості
риба душі критично дивлюся тієї так
ласти більше за мету щоб вони промови були
досягнуто за крима україна моя контролю
вати свої кордони muse та латинською
кварталі овешки вас броня та російські
вся кава
моя взяв і шиті донбас залишилося на її
думка європа травня розпад шато але от
дискусію причин навички на не
мінських домовленостей